the vatican it's not a building but an
independent sovereign state
but given its size and the fact that it
exists entirely in case by the city of
rome the obvious question is
why why is the vatican an independent
country
well to begin the vatican has previously
been at the heart of an independent
state
the papal states which came into
existence in the 8th century when it was
cut off from the remnants of the
byzantine empire in italy when the
lombards conquered this territory the
pope then asked the franks for help who
gave it and kingpip and the short gifted
the pope these lands
so despite being occupied several times
over the course of its life the papal
states managed to survive all the way to
the 18th century when napoleon happened
like all things napoleon couldn't last
forever and in 1815 after he was
defeated the congress of vienna brought
the papal states back from the dead
there was a problem though the french
had not only conquered parts of italy
but spread the idea of nationalism to
the divided italian people there this
idea of an italian nation-state in italy
saw the kingdom of piedmont sardinia
lead the charge
by 1860 it had grown to this and now
consisted of most of the former papal
territory
except for san marino because reasons
they didn't take all of it because
napoleon iii
had offered the pope protection and
station troops in rome where they stayed
until 1870 when war broke out between
france and prussia and those troops had
to leave victor emmanuel wanted roman so
after the pope refused a peaceful
annexation he ordered an invasion
the vatican was placed under siege and
the pope made it clear that whoever
ordered the assault on the city would be
excommunicated
which the italians got around by finding
a jewish soldier and getting him to do
it instead because she can't
excommunicate someone who isn't
christian
the city was taken and rome became
italy's new capital after which its
rulers and popes there probably went
back to ignoring each other
so when did things change there have
been numerous attempts to change the
vatican status but all failed
because you know god's representative on
earth italian leaders wanted the pope's
status sorted since the church had
immense way on voters but also they
wanted their new nation to remain
territorially intact
it was in the late 1920s when the
italian prime minister benito mussolini
pushed for a permanent solution
after some negotiations the italian and
papal governments came to an agreement
the lateran accords
this established the vatican city is an
independent nation made up of this
territory in the city of rome making it
the smallest nation in the world
the italian government agreed to pay
compensation to the pope for lands lost
in the previous century
whereas the vatican agreed to adopt all
italian laws for the purposes of
cross-border enforcement
and even after the fall of mussolini the
end of the italian monarchy in 1946 the
new italian republic agreed to continue
to recognize the treaty as the
foundation for the vatican city-state
which remains in force to this day
in the end it's important to realize
that the existence of an independent
nation ran from the vatican by the pope
is not unusual but in fact had been the
norm for over a thousand years
barring a few interruptions i hope you
enjoyed this episode and thank you for
watching with a special thanks to my
patrons
james bissonette kelly moneymaker
anthony beckett
the pastry section danny maloney rob
waterhouse
mo aaron the white james castaneda
jordan longley
jerry lamdin marcus asner gustav swann
john bailey
colin castleman rasheed ali spinning
three plates filter oink oink izzy
david silverman maggie paxkowski winston
caywood
spencer lightfoot robert wetzel
fortunate calf lexi schwinn
skye chappelle and marvin cassell